don't judge yourself in the daling judge
yourself in the yearly and slow it down
be patient
you got your prospective
[Music]
I enjoyed paying my dues I loved when I
was 28 on December 9th working a
register because it was busy in the
store and having my friends from college
come to the store in their BMW because
they worked on Wall Street and they're
buying a case of wine and they're like
looking dead in my face and I know what
they're thinking which is they just
pulled up into my store and their BMW
and I'm the help going downstairs to
pick up their case of champagne I
enjoyed those moments because I knew
exactly how it's gonna play out for me
happiness is being able to do what you
want to do at all times just being able
to do what you want to do wouldn't want
that and I think that is one of the
great things about entrepreneurs the
perfect cost of that is you're always
one second away from dying right
entrepreneurship is scary like one
second you're the top of the world next
thing you know like there is nobody
behind you you're the last line it's
like fighting a war just you do the
laughs this is the castle you know
everybody's been fighting you so that's
lonely that's scary but you get to
define it you get to tell when everybody
is where they position this how they
should find it and so I love that
feeling I love being in that place
loving what you do is so on you know
people hear that it's you know even when
I was a kid alone on a boat like you
know it's very fluffy
but it's very truthful it's like being
happy and what you do and whether that's
making forty five thousand a year for
four million a year
if you really love it and you're really
doing what you want to be doing that's a
very very good place to be you're just
gonna be happy and I I genuinely do
think we have a major branding issue on
success and I mean across seven point
seven billion people every part of the
world and and I'm very passionate about
REITs like being one of the voices that
tries to redefine it because I'm
unbelievably not driven by money
unbelievably I spent the first 12 years
of my life building the family business
from a three to a sixty million our
business for my parents and left at 34
years old with nothing to my name then
started a company with my brother was
coming out of college and made him a
50/50 partner and then he left four
years later and I spent tens of millions
of dollars to buy him out like money
does not drive
McKeen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm unbelievably in tune with the fact
that it's almost impossible to become a
human being and I have no interest for
taking that for granted
like like if I love with analytical
people like out so when I have a very
deeply math kid in front of me and we're
having some sort of debate and they're
upset about something I'm like you know
the odds of being a human being or 400
trillion to one right like I think that
what drives me is an unbelievably clear
perspective to how lucky we are to have
an at-bat and I'm struggling to dwell on
dumb [ __ ] as long as eight people that I
love more than life are alive that
morning I'm in good spirits I really am
yeah you know like look I think I think
adversity and humble beginnings is an
incredibly good framework to happiness
if you layer positivity and optimism
around your difficulty a lot of times
people look at their difficult thing
dwell and go the other way so for me
what it's like I'm excited every day cuz
I get to play and yes I love competing
but I I love competing more than I love
the game more than the trophy that the
game gives me and that is also another
happy part but I have my perspective and
Shaq I really do and I don't just say it
I live it and what's really fun for me
is that I'm a little bit older when this
is all happened so I have a lot of
people my life who've known me long
before I ever made one single piece of
content the internet in the wine world
let alone what it's manifested into and
it's funny when once in a blue moon if
some things fester and and you know
there's a little bit of push back
against me it's really fun to see like
amber school in high school in college
and early wine people jump into me like
business who me [ __ ] you think this
is somebody else this is the way this
dude was when nobody was watching you
know I've always been very grateful I'm
very grateful I'm very grateful
[Music]
you should always be doing what you want
you don't know yet
not at first like to your point if you
do something for a year and a half and
nobody gives a [ __ ] now you're
delusional but but but notice that I'm
giving you an answer based on where
you're right now if you don't have a
podcast yet you should start with what
you loved because the only way you're
going to do something hard enough is if
you want it you know so you start with
something you love you do it for a year
you feel it out and you know if you're
now into year two and nobody still lives
matter now it's you know people people
always said that hardest question to ask
is when should you double down on
staying the course and persevering or
when should you bail and shut it down
you never really like I could never
answer that question there's too much I
need to know to answer that question but
in the beginning point it's very easy
for me to answer
do something you [ __ ] love because if
you're doing something you think will do
well you're now already in a place where
it's gonna be hard for you to make your
content enough passionate about it you
have so many other [ __ ] you're gonna
choose what else is better or easier
like you know it's hard to get going
around something you don't feel great
about you're just doing it for what for
listening to subscribes for what I mean
I'm so passionately trying to get people
to realize happy is better than money
I'm passionate about this I'm passionate
about this it's a very important
conversation that we feel like we have
to do if we want to really really really
change it we have to redefine that
success looks like it is just not how
many subscribers you have it is not how
much money it's just not
and people are pandering to the machines
the algorithms the descriptions and
ultimately why for the money right
you're gonna pander for those Christians
and for the likes because that leads to
the brand deals the money and this is
like something that I think we need to
talk about it's something we're now
mature enough in this ecosystem that
it's time for us to now have more
thoughtful conversations we still have
we have to start having this
conversation I know it's out of that
like what you do after it too much
balance between creating fun time are
you able to afford not doing your job
because my bit money my sizes are this
in the hive like very my content can you
cook can you control your expenses again
I mean that's you know it's a very
practical answer like I get that one
would want to you know you got a nail
down it is after your job obviously
you'd love to not have to do you've only
got two option wait to your side hustles
get to enough that you can leave your
job or leave your job and live way more
humbly with roommates or back home or
whatever the hell it is those are the
only two real options
big time yeah I think three at the same
time is fine I don't think I don't think
you're stretched too thin or doing too
many things I think that that's great if
you could maintain it as long as you
don't mentally burn out yeah and even if
by the way do three things burn out and
drop one it's at one you know what I
mean like what works today doesn't have
to be what works tomorrow right this is
one big game of self-awareness it's not
how I want it it's not how you want it
it's how you need it for yourself
you just need to keep asking yourself
what do you need and what you need today
is different than what you're going to
need tomorrow and it's different than
what you needed yesterday this is a
forever evolving thing evolved to what
feels right today not what you think it
should be you guys I've been doing
okay so there's one thing you want to
tell every creative out there that's
what doing out is trying to write get up
to day Korea what would that one thing
be it takes years a great creative work
to get to that place like stop judging
yourself
just cuz this one video didn't get as
many views are not as many likes don't
judge yourself in the daily judge
yourself in the yearly and slow it down
be patient be patient
I love that thank you so just as one of
your life
I mean I struggled when I was a kid
because I hated school but since I've
been a grown up not so not really and
I'll tell you why
anytime I start getting sad I get sad
like anybody else I immediately put
things in perspective and here's what I
do like context like just cuz this
business thing or just because these
people said this thing about me what
like what would happen if my mom died
today
bye guys the women out there we're gonna
say listen listen I have so much respect
because you guys deal with so many extra
dynamics that dudes don't so I would say
keep persevering you got this thank you
so much you're welcome bye
[Music]
the one that is just really really
really big for me right now is how many
kids don't want to do with their parents
want them to do but aren't willing to
pay the sacrifices to do what they want
to do but they don't know Gary like they
do they they know they they do they do
they don't want to pay the price they
still want their parents to pay for
their rent they still want their parents
to pay for their uber they still want
like they think that they're in control
of what their parents are willing to
give when so many when you want
something from somebody you're not in
control of what they give yeah like
would you live at home you live under
their rule my big thing that always
makes me laugh is like like there was
this kid the other day that got really
upset with me I'm like like really upset
with me during a Q&A because I wouldn't
invest in his company and finally I said
to him like it was really actually like
a scene and I was like bro you're asking
huh like he was mad at me I'm like I'm
not asking you for anything and and
that's a very like when you're asking
for something you don't have the
leverage like period like you you don't
want to go to college you don't have to
go to college you don't want to be a
doctor you don't have to go be a doctor
right but that also means that if that's
what your parents want and that's what
they're willing to pay for you can't be
like hey mom you know how you're gonna
give me 80 thousand to go be a doctor
that that's what you you want well I
don't want that I want to be a painter
so give me that 80 thousand that's not
her you have to leave that on the table
that money that infrastructure comes
with that ambition like if you want that
safety and that money well that means
you're gonna be a lawyer if you want to
be a [ __ ] motorcycle racer that means
you're gonna live in a studio apartment
with 19 friends people ask the dumbest
[ __ ] this kidney other things like Gary
Vee but how do you do this in the Bay
Area it's so expensive like you move
dick you don't live in the Bay Area you
have a choice pure like Gary look what
the [ __ ] like you're trying to pay $14
an hour how do you survive in New York
City I'm like you live in Queens and you
take there like like you can do anything
you have options people aren't willing
to sacrifice for what they want they
this is why I jump on they don't know
they know people don't want to deal with
the truth what you know there's two
things I do I keep it basic and I go
right at my question actually isn't for
me it's for my son
[Music]
Giovanni Giovanni he wants to be a
twitch streamer sounds aged struggled
with so I'm wondering if you can give
him a few words what can you can do what
type of actions you can take today to
build this confidence Shivani I think
the question you know I see we're
recording this look when you're 10 years
old
confidence is a very funny thing they're
still forming as a human but the reality
is is if you're twitching and you're
over responding to how many subscribers
you have or what your friends in school
are saying you're not going to be able
to be successful and so you're lucky
Giovanni to be able to start this
process now not when you're 45 years old
the quicker you get comfortable with
judgment of others the more likely
you'll be successful long-term the way
to get your confidence up is to start
enjoying the push back is to start
enjoying people say that you can't is to
start enjoying the judgment of others
who don't understand if you're not
comfortable in your own framework you'll
never succeed
[Music]
[Applause]
love you guys I gotta catch my flight
but I love you thank you for coming love
you back thank you thank you yeah Ellie
love it great energy in there yeah it
was thank you good to see you in Sydney
can't wait
thank you so much you know thank you
thank you bye guys bye bye thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude I'm so fired up about this so nice
you know what this is do you know what
it is this is a replication of the
single thing that I value the most in
the entire universe when I was seven
years old
and we moved to New Jersey and I became
a Jets fan my friends had jerseys and I
came home one day and they said mom
everybody has a jersey I want one and we
couldn't afford to buy a $20 Jersey so
week later my mom knitted me one this is
the exact thing she knitted this is
exactly what it looks like with my name
on the back and the reason I do five is
because five was my favorite number even
as that little bit kid and that's what
they said this is exactly I can't wait
to wear this
I can't wait like hope it's super cold
in your
[Music]
[Applause]
too much overthinking in the system
that was the theme of the keynote great
tripping KL Malaysia I love you
Singapore thank you for your time d-roc
thank you for your support
leave a comment subscribe or d-roc will
cry
see if you can leave a comment there is
flog
oh I don't mean on camera and in the
comments section on YouTube
[Music]
should we name this character
[Music]